Hey did you know that
around 72 percent of all men
and 74% of all women are not satisfied
with the way that they look and in a lot
of cases this leads to low self-esteem
and that influences your whole life. Now
have you ever actually asked yourself
why do you feel this way? It is because
you're brainwashed every single day by
movies, TV series and the media. You
see beautiful models on billboards and
magazines and every shop. But I'm gonna
tell you a secret: I'm one of those
models, I've been traveling
internationally for over 13 years and
over 15 different countries and most
models feel exactly the same way. We are
not a hundred percent happy with
ourselves. You know modeling is the job
where you get rejected the most based on
your looks. They say you're not what they
want because you're not tall enough,
you're not skinny enough, you're not big
enough, you don't have enough muscles, you don't have the ABS they want, your abs
are skew, you have the wrong eye color,
you have the wrong hair color, your
forehead is too big, you have the wrong
haircut, your ears are too big... I mean my
goodness I've been rejected so many
times that I've lost count and then even
if I am lucky to get that job over 20 or
50 or a hundred other models out there
then they will still add some makeup and
style my hair to cover those
imperfections and then after the photo
shoot is done they Photoshop it to hide
those imperfections even more so that it
is perfect according to them. That is not
reality. You won't even recognize most models if you see them in the street. if you
compare it to how they look and
billboards or magazines. So stop
comparing yourself to models or even
celebrities because you are unique.
You've been wonderfully made and there
is no one out there in the whole world
like you. I'm quickly gonna go through a
list. I'm gonna give you nine things
that's gonna help you to be content
with the way that you look. So let's
start with the first one:
Change your own
definition of beauty because you won't
be able to change the media's ideals of
beauty. So don't focus on the fake beauty.
Focus on real life beauty. Beauty that
you see in everyday life. The beauty of
unique people where nobody is the same
and remember
beauty is in the eye of the beholder.
Remind yourself that with time beauty fades
just like grass or plants it fades and
so you got to define yourself with not
just your outer look but with your inner
look, meaning your inner qualities which
is more important. This is an area where
we all can improve ourselves immensely
by focusing more on your abilities, your
character, your relationships and your
perspective on life. You know after
losing two brothers in my life and also
recently my father to cancer I realized
that those relationships with people in
your life is so much more important than
material things and even things like
worrying about how you look constantly
every day
Focus more on the good things in your
life and smile more. Research shows that
people who smile more looks more
attractive to other people. Think about
it:
Do you want to hang out with people that
aren't just pessimistic and negative
all the time, who never smiles... Or do you want to hang out of people who are positive
and friendly and makes you feel better?
You gotta go cold turkey!
Daniel what do you mean go cold turkey? I'm not an alcoholic
or something here... Well this is what I'm
talking about: Go cold turkey from trying
to be perfect all the time. Just for a
few days. Just let it go... let go from
always trying to style your hair to
perfection and from wearing the most stylish
clothes. Just go natural with your hair.
Dress comfortable and let it go just for
a few days. If you do it you will feel
less pressure to always try to fit
in and also you'll feel truer to
yourself.
Take a break from the mirror
How many times per day do you look in
the mirror? Stop looking at yourself so
much in the mirror or even in
reflections of windows. Just take a break
and focus on changing the inside instead
of trying to fix the outside of your
appearance the whole time
Take a break from social media and from
following celebrities. You know it's
often said that we are what we eat, right?
And often we think just about food, right?
Let me ask you what are you feeding your
soul? Who are you listening to all the
time? Instead of looking to celebrities
or even Youtubers that feed your soul of
stuff that just makes you feel bad
follow and list to people that makes
your soul better, like me (joking).
Realize perfection is an illusion.
There's no such thing as perfection.
No one is perfect but every single person
even you, yes you are an original. You have
to learn to strive for continuous growth
and improvement
instead of perfection. You know being a
model, the fashion industry has always
pointed out my flaws to me. Even here on my YouTube channel some people said hey
Daniel your eyebrows are
all screwed up! Well... yeah I've got a
scar here. Or they would say: "your
forehead is so big" well, yes I got a big
forehead. That's me. Some other people say: "Wow man you've got the worst genes ever
your chest is wide apart from each other
why is that?" Well again it's my genes...
It's who I am. I'm human just like you but
I'm completely 100% content and happy
with who I am. With who God made me to be. It's who I am and you should be happy
with yourself as well because it's who
you are.
Find your worth in your character not on
your appearance or in your achievements
Where do you find your value? What do you base it on? On your appearance ?Because we
all know that beauty fades...
On what other people say? Because
we all know that other people always
have other opinions about everything
I personally base my value as a human
being not on all these other things but
on my character and also who God made me to be
Accept yourself. If you can't accept
yourself how do you expect other people
to accept you? A few guys asked me on the channel: "Hey Daniel how can I get more
confidence in myself". Well here's the
thing: When you truly accept yourself the
way you look your genes everything about
you I mean we can all improve ourselves
right?
But those basic things who you are. If
you accept it, then you start to gain
confidence in yourself and the world
will accept it too and those that don't
they don't matter
If you like the video give it a thumbs
up subscribe and we will talk soon